speaking of which Donald Trump used to
blame President Obama for looking tired
he has now bailed on an event during his
Middle East trip due to exhaustion that
is being widely reported Ivanka Trump
spoke at the tweets youth forum in
Riyadh an event to talk about combating
extremism on social media because Trump
was just too tired
Trump abruptly skipped the event on the
second day of his trip in Saudi Arabia
and the day before he was due to meet
with Israeli leaders to negotiate a
peace process with Palestine he was
already exhausted a White House official
was asked by reporters why is Trump
deviating from his prepared speech
earlier the two Muslim leaders about
fighting Islamic terrorism he said
something like Islamic versus Islamist
or there was some word that he changed
and the response from the White House
was that Trump is quote just an
exhausted guy Donald Trump attacked
Obama for looking tired Donald Trump
attacked Hillary Clinton for her quote
lack of stamina when footage captured
her being helped into a car after a 9/11
memorial ceremony in New York City
remember when Donald Trump tweeted quote
Hillary Clinton doesn't have the
strength or stamina to be President Jeb
Bush is a low-energy individual but
Hillary is not much better during the
first 2016 presidential debate Donald
Trump said that Hillary Clinton doesn't
have the stamina to be President in fact
he's talked about more than just Hillary
Clinton there have been countless tweets
that Donald Trump sent out indicating
that other people look tired Obama looks
exhausted and beaten President Obama
looks absolutely exhausted not a natural
leader Bernie is exhausted he just wants
to shut down and go home to bed I always
said that debbie Wasserman Schultz was
overrated the Dems convention is
cracking up and Bernie is exhausted no
energy left may I remind people that
Donald Trump's doctor said as we see
other comments about Bernie being
exhausted and other people being
exhausted that if elected Trump
could be would be the healthiest
individual ever to be elected to the
presidency this is actually not
something to make fun of honestly I mean
it appears as though Trump can't keep up
with it he's not the youngest guy he's
overweight he eats unhealthily from all
of the pictures that we've seen III
don't think it's something to make fun
of
yes it's yet another example of Donald
Trump's endless endless hypocrisy but
this is just a sort of sad thing it's
another projection - and we know that he
likes to do that but he's not too keen
on the idea of traveling this was his
first visit as president overseas and
apparently he barked at a White House
aide and wanted to make sure that the
trip was half as long as initially
planned for do you know how long the
trip is in total I actually don't know
it's good it's nine days okay apparently
a little bit too much for Trump so again
there is nothing I can find that Trump
criticized Hillary Clinton for or Obama
for that he is not guilty of himself